hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today well we're gonna talk
about a continuation of what happened in
the last video in the last video our big
idea was quantum mechanics but as I said
in that video I wasn't gonna do the
whole story but for one thing quantum
mechanics is too big to have just in one
video but for another thing quantum
mechanics very naturally falls into the
sort of down and dirty let's put it to
work and use it kind of stuff that is
99% of what businesses actually worry
about how we teach quantum mechanics and
our textbooks to our students how we put
it to use in our everyday life doing
calculations and then the deeper
questions about it and this is roughly
the division not exactly but roughly the
division that I'm using in these two
videos so the previous one quantum
mechanics was on what you learn in the
textbooks and as a that's a 2nd year
sophomore physics major today we're
going to talk about entanglement
now entanglement is of course a basic
feature of quantum mechanics you don't
need to be fancy or philosophical to get
into entanglement it's right there front
and center and yet when we teach our
students quantum mechanics we more or
less ignore it I taught a class at
Caltech a couple years ago it was the
last quarter Caltech has three quarters
three terms during the academic year so
it's the last term of a three term
sequence on quantum mechanics for
third-year undergraduates and I just did
nothing but entanglement because they
had basically not been exposed to it
they'd gotten like some of the very very
very basics but it's a subject within
quantum mechanics that is largely
ignored or at least under emphasized
this is one of the big motivations I
have I think I've told many of you that
I'm currently working on an
undergraduate quantum textbook myself
because I think that most current
quantum textbooks do not take
entanglement seriously enough now this
will lead us very naturally into deep
questions in the interpretation of
quantum mechanics and so it's a sort of
very natural umbrella topic as usual in
these videos I'm using my big idea to
talk about many little sub ideas so the
talk that we're gonna have about the
foundations of quantum mechanics is here
in this video on entanglement but let me
first try to explain where entanglement
comes from because members furniture
came up with this idea
that we talk about quantum systems in
terms of a wavefunction
sigh of X and T the wave function and
you might very well think well what is
the difference really or why is there
any difference between schrödinger's
wave function and an ordinary classical
field right if you have electromagnetism
you have the electric field which is a
function of X and T you have the
magnetic field which is a function of X
and T so it looks to me like the wave
function is a similar kind of Beast it's
something that takes on the value at
every point in space-time let me erase
this because we're from out
electromagnetism
so the difference is that this
particular version of the wave function
of the quantum state looks like a field
but only because it's only applicable to
when there is one particle so this is
the wave function of one particle at a
time as soon as your quantum system
becomes any more complicated than one
particle the quantum state no longer
looks like a field and the reason why is
because of entanglement and I'm going to
look we don't need to go in order here
so let me skip ahead to the answer the
answer is that when you have multiple
particles or multiple degrees of freedom
more generally you don't have a wave for
each one of them there is only one wave
that depends on the whole thing you have
the wave function of the universe as
Stephen Hawking liked to call it I
believe that the idea of the wave
function of the universe was first
coined by none other than Hugh Everett
who was the inventor of the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics at
least he called it that maybe he got it
from John Wheeler whose advisor so if
you have just let's say n particles
okay let's imagine the universe has n
particles in it and forget about spins
and fields and all those complication
let's just imagine n particles the wave
function of those n particles is going
to be psy of the location of particle
one location of particle two location of
particle three etc
up to the location of particle n and of
course what time it is okay so this is
very different so this is not what you
might guess that you have psy for
particle one as a function of where it
can be psy a particle two four where it
can be etc so this is not what you get
in quantum mechanics there is only one
wavefunction for everything and you can
interpret this as saying well you know
how do we interpret the regular wave
function for each X for each location
the particle can be in there's a number
a complex number sy of X and we square
that number take the real part squared
plus the imaginary part squared that is
the probability of observing the
particle in that particular location so
when we have this big thing the wave
function of the universe you separately
give me the possible places that every
single particle can be in particle one
is here particle two is over there
particle three is over here okay and for
every collection of all the places they
could be you can square that number
there's a complex number called the wave
function the amplitude is that sometimes
used equivalently there's an amplitude
associated with that particular
configuration you square it and that's
the probability that were you to look at
every particle all at once that's where
you would see them so this is a
different thing than just a field living
on space or space-time
okay the wave function is not a function
of space time when you have more than
one particle it's a function of the
configuration space of all the possible
particles in space-time or all the
fields or what have you okay
that was jumping ahead that was the
answer to where we're gonna go why how
do we know this what gave us this
particular idea that's that's a good
question so imagine that you have two
particles coming in so let's say you
have particle one it's coming in it's
moving in some direction and you have
particle two that's gonna they're gonna
collide okay now you should imagine that
of course these particles are little
waves and they have little packets that
are more or less localized in space so
that there's a good approximation in
which we can talk about the two
particles collide
okay so we do this all the time when we
talk about quantum mechanics we hop back
and forth between the reality that we
know is quantum and wave functions and
the language that we use which is
particles and trajectories and stuff
like that as long as we're in a regime
where that kind of approximation is
valid that's a perfectly legitimate
thing for us to do now what's gonna
happen is these particles are gonna
collide they're gonna interact and
they're gonna go off at some angle right
so they're gonna collide and they're
gonna scatter so particle two goes off
this way maybe particle one goes off
this way for example okay and if they
were fields if these were like two wave
packets in the electromagnetic field
they would just do exactly that the ways
would come in they would scatter because
their waves not particles they would not
go on definite trajectories out in
different directions they would scatter
in some wide pattern okay but it would
still make perfect sense from that field
perspective they would have gone from
being localized to being all smashing
and going out in all the different
directions but quantum mechanics kind of
changes things because we know that
these are waves it makes perfect sense
to imagine that as the waves come in
they sort of interfere and bang into
each other and go out in some smushy
spherical disturbance going off in all
different directions but when we observe
them that's not what we see quantum
mechanics says we see a particle with a
particular location a particular
trajectory okay it's the combination of
those two facts that the wavefunction
moves out in a spherical pattern but
when we observe it we see the particle
moving in a certain place at a certain
velocity that's what makes this
entanglement stuff happen so what you
might imagine doing from this picture
you might imagine trying to predict the
probability that you get particle one
detected let's imagine you have some
detector out here looking for particle
once of the detector out here looking
for particle two and you can detect the
two particles you can figure out what
angle they moved at there's some angle
theta at which the particle scattered
okay a typical thing that a particle
physicist might want to do but you don't
need to detect them both at the same
time let's say you detect particle one
first so you have a little detector here
and it notes that right here is where
particle one
hit but from the wave function you might
have a implied that it could have hit
there it could have hit there it could
have hit anywhere there's a different
probability for going in different
places okay when you notice that
particle one hits there you can also
measure particle tubes hitting somewhere
and what you will find is that you can
predict where particle one will be
observed by using conservation of
momentum so this particle one little
wave packet that was almost particle
like is associated with a trajectory
that has a certain momentum it's moving
at a certain velocity and the particle
has a certain mass likewise particle two
does that's a total momentum of the two
particles coming in that is conserved as
the two particles go out okay what that
means is that when you observe particle
one after after the collision would let
me say this way after the collision you
don't know what you're going to observe
for the momentum of particle one or
particle two but if you measure particle
one figure out what its momentum was by
figuring out what direction it moved in
then if you want momentum to be
conserved it suddenly has to be the case
that you know the direction in which
particle two is moving right because you
know what the momentum particle one was
now and you know with a initial momentum
or so you can figure out where particle
two was going so somehow the fact that
you measured particle 1 tells you what
the momentum particle two is whether or
not you measured it that's entanglement
so in this case we motivated it by the
combination of particles or wave
functions and you predict their
probabilities plus we want momentum to
be conserved now maybe one of those
principles was not true so really
entanglement is just a fact about the
world we're not deriving it for
axiomatically from some set of
postulates it is a fact about the world
but you can motivate it by saying that
if you want quantum mechanics as we
teach it in textbooks to be correct and
you want momentum to be more or less
conserved when we do these scattering
experiments then there has to be some
entanglement between the particles and
the entanglement just means that when we
do that quantum states
are not functions if you think about
quantum state is assigning an amplitude
which you then square I should I should
mean let me let me be more clear about
this actually because I am using a
little bit of vocabulary here that you
don't know so size sign for one single
particle X at T this whole thing that
whole function is called the wave
function okay or the quantum state but a
particular value if we fix X the vector
X the three-dimensional location space
to be some value let's call it X star
okay then the value then the wave
function has a value X Sol y of X star
of T this is a complex number right
there's a particular complex number it's
not a function because we've fixed the
value X there's one particular complex
number for each X and I've told you what
X is so the wave function now tells me
what the complex number is not very good
representation of the number sign and
that is called the amplitude the
amplitude associated with the particle
being at location X okay so the wave
function is the collection of all the
different amplitudes for all the
different possible things you can
observe good so entanglement is just the
statement that wave functions quantum
states more generally associate
amplitudes with the entire configuration
of a system
not not individually part by part so in
other words when you have two particles
you do not have an amplitude for one
particle to be here and a separate
amplitude for the other particle to be
there
you tell me where both particles could
be every single possible combination and
you sign an amplitude to each one of
those and entanglement is the fact that
if you learn something by observing one
of the system particles one of the
particles or subsystems involved that
can be related to the other ones so let
me give you let me give you a simpler
example of this we often actually look
at this in terms of spins so the spin of
a particle is a something you can
observe for something like an electron
the spin of an electron is either up or
down so for an electron we say that you
Majan a little electron here and there's
a little axis if it's rotating this way
we measure the spin along the vertical
axis which is usually the z axis we
usually draw axes this way X Y Z and as
conventional don't ask me why
that we measure spin along the z axis
but we're allowed to measure it along
any axis we want so we measure it and we
get either that it is up which means
that if you put your thumb in the puss Z
Direction the right hand rule applies so
the particle is spinning in the same
direction your fingers of your right
hand would turn around that or it can be
down which is just a fancy way of saying
that the left hand rule would work or
that you put your thumb down and the
right hand rule would work okay and
again this is a at this level of
analysis that we're giving you right
here this is just a fact
unlike position of an electron or
something like that
where there is a continuous infinity of
possible values the position can take
there's any single location in space it
could be at spin is either up or down so
you can define a qubit a quantum
mechanical bit
which is some number call it alpha times
spin up which let's draw it this way
little arrow going up plus beta spin
down so alpha and beta are the two
different amplitudes associated with
observing the spin up or observing the
spin down and there is a condition that
if you take alpha squared that's the
probability of observing spin up and if
you add that to beta squared which is
the probability of observing spin down
they had better add up to 1 right
because the total probability of
observing something is equal to 1 there
you go that's all you need to know about
qubits and spin very very good the
reason why we do this is because now we
can combine two different systems so you
have two spins and now you have four
different possible basis states as we
call them we talked we talked about
these two things these two possibilities
spin up or spin down
we call these basis states these are the
states that you would observe the
particles to be in if what you choose to
measure was spin along the Z direction
again you're allowed to measure spin
along whatever direction you want you
get different answers but if you measure
it along the z direction there are two
different answers you could get these
are the two basis States the system
could be in so for two spins there are
four basis of states namely if you take
spin one call this particle one and
spin-2 particle two they could both be
up that's one possibility
spin one could be up and spin two could
be down spin one could be down and spin
two could be up or squeezing things over
here let me see if I can do this
good look at that they could both be
down that's the other possibility okay
so there are four different
possibilities for this combination of
two spins at once they're not
independent from each other so the wave
function sy for these two spins may be
sy is alpha times spin up and well let
me let me pick a good
one year now let me just make my life
very very simple okay maybe the
wavefunction is both spins are up that's
a perfectly allowed wave function there
you go
but maybe the wave function is I'm going
to put a 1 over square root of 2 here
because I told you that the squares of
all the amplitudes should add up to 1
and I'm going to have two different
amplitudes so maybe I could have a
combination that they're both up plus
they're both down that's another allowed
state that we can be in so you notice
that there are two different different
components as we say contributing to
this wave function both of them have a
coefficient 1 over square root of 2 so
you square them it's 1/2 each 1/2 plus
1/2 equals 1 probability is conserved
good so in this wave function in this
quantum state let's call this instead of
1 or 2 let's do something more
conventional we often call these spins a
and B and then to be slightly clever and
witty we associate a with Alice who has
the first spin and B with Bob who has
the second spin okay so there's Alice's
spin and Bob's spin and in this first
state that's called this side one side
two two different examples of what the
wave function could be inside one when
Alice measures her spin in the Z
direction she's gonna find that it's
spin up when Bob measures his he's gonna
find it as spin down it was really sorry
that it's spin up also there's no
ambiguity about that force I - if that's
the configuration that both spins are in
then if Alice measures hers here's
Alice's spin here and here this is both
this notation means that the first arrow
in those parentheses is Alice's spin and
this is a superposition of two different
possibilities and one of those
possibilities Alice's spin is up in the
other it's down in both cases the
amplitude is 1 over square root of 2
which is the square root of 1/2 so Alice
doesn't know what she's going to see she
might measure the spin to be up she
might measure the spin to be down Bob
likewise Bob's gonna measure this one
and it could be up where it could be
down but if Alice measures her spin and
she gets that it is spin up then
suddenly we erased that possibility from
existence if Alice measures spin up the
wavefunction collapses and now we're
only left with this piece and in that
piece Bob's spin is also up so if Alice
measures her spin to be up we know
instantly that Bob's spin will also be
up okay I'm gonna erase these because
they a little sloppy but that's the
thing that you should have in mind an
observation collapses the wave function
in an entangled wave function collapsing
the wave function of one part of it can
have an effect on other parts okay what
is the effect it can change the
probability that the observer who
measures that other things going to get
different possible measurement outcomes
in this case if you measured spin up for
Alice you're gonna get spin up for Bob
and vice-versa if Alice measures spin
down well we'll get spin down or if Bob
measures at first Alice will also get
the same one it's always going to be the
case that Alice and Bob get the same
answer so side one is not entangled this
one is entangled sometimes people look
at me funny because they're used to
seeing there's another wave function I
could write side three one over square
root of two where Alice and Bob spin are
anti-correlated so if alice is up then
bob is down and if alice is down bob is
up this is also entangled
it's just entangled in a different way
so the spins are always opposite to each
other there's a physics reason why Tsai
3 here appears more often it turns out
to be a lower lower energy state two
different physical systems a proton
who's has an electron that is anti
correlated with it is in a lower energy
state than that they're in the same
direction but these are both examples
both side two here in side three are
examples of quantum states the two spins
could be in where there is entanglement
because all entanglement means is when
you measure one subsystem you instantly
know something about the other sub
now this idea of entanglement was raised
you know it took a while not not very
long
you know quantum mechanics sort of came
into its mature form around 1927 at the
5th solve a conference when Einstein and
Bohr were arguing and Schrodinger and
poly and Heisenberg and the whole gang
was there talking to each other but it
wasn't until Einstein and Schrodinger
had a bunch of correspondence they sent
letters back and forth and they were
fetching they were complaining about the
Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics which they didn't like you
know Einstein very famously thought that
quantum mechanics was not the final
answer he understood quantum mechanics
as well as anyone he was not against it
he's thought it was a stepping stone to
something more profound something deeper
and he was advocating that people look
for that deeper thing and they didn't
listen to him
so his most famous argument was the 1935
EPR paper Einstein Podolsky and Rosen
einstein-rosen we're good friends who
collaborated a lot Mayan Stein Podolsky
arose and Podolski was a younger guy and
the rumor is well I know if it's a rumor
but what I read was Podolski when when
EPR wrote their paper
Podolski leaked it to the New York Times
and New York Times had like a front-page
story about this paper in theoretical
physics and Einstein was furious he was
furious both of the New York Times and
at Podolski in fact that what I've read
is that he never talked to Podolski
again so don't blab about your work with
your famous advisor to the New York
Times you could get in trouble anyway
this is the EPR paper which became very
famous and it's a little bit
misunderstood sometimes because people
sometimes get the idea that you know
again I in sign was just clutching he
was just complaining that he didn't like
quantum mechanics and then this this is
the paper that introduced the concept
not the phrase but the concept of spooky
action at a distance
which you know goes down and infamy as
at a distance as a complaint about
quantum mechanics and you can see what
it is I don't need to do it in detail if
you have
sigh if you have the wave function of
this form 1 over square root of 2 let's
use the conventional thing that people
like just so everyone's happy up-down
plus down-up okay so the spins are
oppositely aligned and here is Alice on
planet Earth
she's staying behind she's gonna measure
her spin but we sent Bob out to Alpha
Centauri and there's a planet orbiting
Alpha Centauri in Bob's Hoonah measure
his spin there so we create two
entangled spins that's not hard to do
you can do that in lab very easily
you've handed one to Alice you had one
to Bob you say don't observe them yet
you send Bob out on a spaceship it takes
them several years to get to Alpha
Centauri and then you say now you're
allowed to look at them and the point is
that if that's in this form right here
then when Alice measures hers she
doesn't know what answer she's gonna get
it could be spin up or spin down but
once she does that measurement then the
wavefunction collapses everywhere
according to the conventional Copenhagen
rules of quantum mechanics
so we instantly know that whatever
answer Alice got Bob is going to get the
opposite answer this bugged Einstein it
is true you know you can't really argue
about that because Einstein had invented
special relativity he'd invented the
rules that you're not allowed to move
faster than the speed of light it seems
like information is moving faster than
the speed of light but Alice did
something and that instantly changed the
state of Bob's spin if Alice measures
spin up we know that Bob's spin is now
going to be spin down 100% chance okay
how does it know how did the information
get out there because as we talked about
you know in the space-time video if you
have two events that are separated
outside their light cones space like
separation you can't even say
universally which one happens first
right so in someone's perspective alice
measures hers and then Bob measures his
but in someone else's perspective Bob
measured his first and then Alice
measured hers and so which one is that
that caused the other one to collapse
and this you know this would as you
might expect Dr Einstein crazy now it
seems if you think about it that this
thought experiment exploits a little bit
loophole it violates the spirit of
special relativity but not the letter of
the law because Bob does not get any
information from Alice measuring her
spin you cannot use this kind of
entanglement to actually communicate
there's literally a theorem you can
derive that you can't communicate with
people just by measuring entangled
systems that you share with each other
because if you think of it
alice measures let's say spin up she
knows now that Bob spin is a hundred
percent spin down by the collapse of the
wavefunction but Bob doesn't know that
if Bob thought that his spin was 50% of
50% down before Alice did her
measurement that's still what he thinks
Alice could send him a message right
saying hey I measured spin up therefore
you're gonna measure spin down but to
send that message he needs to like send
him a message using ordinary slower than
light communication or it's light speed
communication channels so no information
is actually communicated between Alice
and Bob but somehow an influence of some
sort is being communicated and so it's
not that it is straightforwardly a
contradiction with special relativity
but it does seem to be you know it makes
us uncomfortable a little bit okay
however it's very important to emphasize
here that it's not just making us
uncomfortable you know Einstein and
Podolsky and Rosen were smarter than
that
they didn't write a paper to saying we
are uncomfortable about this they went
on to make an argument and the argument
was something like the following there's
a little bit tricky so let me try to uh
let me try to explain it let me try to
keep this on here so you see the basic
picture they have the following idea so
EPR said if we can predict if we could
let's say in principle predict they said
a bunch of things this is one thing
actually let me let me let me back up
they just took for granted locality so
by which they mean there is no spooky
action at a distance right they just
assume that there is not actually
information that goes from Alice to Bob
even if it's inaccessible to Bob they
just refuse to believe that information
is ipping along fast in the speed of
light no spooky action
at distance again no instantaneous flow
of information and then they also said
they made up this criterion about
elements of reality we don't need to go
into the technical jargon they use but
what they said was if we could in
principle predict with a hundred percent
accuracy what the outcome of an
experiment is going to be then there
must be something real it's hard to say
this in words that everyone would agree
with unless you're just gonna quote them
exactly but the idea is something
pre-existing and real that leads to that
experimental outcome so if you didn't
know that we were doing quantum
mechanics and trying to say subtle
things about experimental outcomes and
spooky action at the distance if someone
said you know if I have a physical setup
where I put a certain physical system
into a certain state and I guarantee
that when you measure a certain property
of that system you will get the
following answer with a hundred percent
certainty and they asked you do you
think it's okay to say okay there's
something real about that system that
reflects that particular measurement
outcome that you are going to get with
100% certainty I think that most people
would say yes that seems reasonable
right that's not a crazy thing to demand
so but what they but that would they
couple that with this locality thing
they say that they say something like
the following if Alice measures the spin
in the vertical direction and gets to
spin up we don't know what alice is
gonna measure they admit that they're
not trying to give you a spooky way a
secret way of saying what else is gonna
get ahead of time they say maybe Ellis
will get spin up maybe spin down but if
she gets spin up then suddenly we know
with a hundred percent certainty what
Bob will get that was got spin up we
know Bob will get spin down okay
so she could have gotten that answer
according to the rules of quantum
mechanics therefore there could be
something definite about what Bob will
get okay furthermore here's that here is
the secret
this could measure Z spin up or down
right or she could measure X spin in
other words she could choose to measure
the spin along a perpendicular axis you
might call these spin right or spin left
two different outcomes that she should
that she could have gotten and it turns
out and there's just a statement that
you're gonna trust me you're gonna take
on faith if the wavefunction Sai is one
over the square root of two spin up spin
down plus spin down spin up then that
equals by mass by changing variables 1
over the square root of 2 spin right
spin left plus spin left spin right in
other words that's a fancy math way of
saying no matter what axis Alice uses to
measure the spin of her particle
whatever answer she gets Bob is gonna
get the other one
Bob spin is anti correlated with Alice
no matter which axis she picks this is
just a fact about quantum mechanics that
we're not gonna bother deriving so EPR
say if alice is what EPR says got to get
it exactly right Alice could choose to
measure the spin in the Z direction and
then we would know what Bob was going to
get therefore whatever she gets there is
some pre-existing fact of the matter
about what Bob would get because no
signal travels faster than the speed of
light in their conception in ordinary
quantum mechanics it does but they don't
they don't allow that okay so they say
that we don't know what Alice is going
to get but she'll get something and
given that she gets something there must
have been something fixed about what Bob
could get but Alice could also measure
in the X direction the same thing is
true so it must therefore be true that
even though we don't know what it is
there must be facts of the matter about
what Bob will get when he measures the
spin either in the X in the Z direction
or the X direction but quantum mechanics
says that
that there cannot be a fact of the
matter about the spin in the Z direction
and the X direction at the same time
quantum mechanics implies the
uncertainty principle which we talked
about last time which implies you can't
predict both Z spin and expanding
simultaneously so I'm again of this
you're taking this on faith I'm stating
it well the way that we stated the
uncertainty principle was a statement
about the uncertainty of position and
momentum it turns out to work exactly
the same way for spin in the vertical
direction or the horizontal direction
you can't have any quantum state with a
definite fact of the matter about what
the spin is in the X direction and a
fact of the matter about what the spin
is in the sorry in the Z direction and
in the X direction so this is the EPR
argument let's see if I can squeeze it
down here so that it's all visible it's
a long argument and they say you know we
set up this thing we imagine doing
experience you'll need to actually do
them we imagine doing them and the
hypothetical outcome of these
experiments implies a fact of the matter
about what reality is doing over at
bob's spin and that fact of the matter
seems to be something that is
incompatible with the basic postulates
of quantum mechanics therefore they say
quantum mechanics must be incomplete
they don't say it's wrong they didn't
say like any of the experimental
predictions of quantum mechanics are
false or anything like that they said
that it can't be the case the quantum
mechanics is the final answer what they
have in mind secretly not so secretly in
their back of their minds is something
like hidden variables that in addition
to the wavefunction there are some other
variables describing the real world and
these other variables travel along with
the spin and these other variables do
know ahead of time whether Bob's gonna
get spin up or spin down or spin left or
spin right okay we don't know because
all we know is the wavefunction so we
assign it a 50/50 probability but the
universe nature God knows
what Bob is gonna get okay that was what
EPR had in mind and they're trying to
they're trying to encourage the rest of
the physics community to go along with
them and it was in fact Schrodinger
commenting on this EP our experiment who
coined the term entanglement as a way of
describing this particular situation so
entanglement makes EPR believe that
quantum mechanics is not done now the
conventional Copenhagen way out of this
is just to deny locality right to say
you know what the world is not local
sorry professor Einstein somehow an
influence propagates from alysus spin
instantaneously to Bob spin that is what
we would teach our undergraduates right
now but of course Einstein didn't want
to admit that and so the quest was on
after EPR to say would it be possible to
construct a version of quantum mechanics
that lived up to what EEP and R were
looking for that is to say a version of
quantum mechanics that was local they
could actually explain all the empirical
predictions of quantum mechanics and
sadly no is roughly speaking the answer
and that is the conclusion of Bell's
Theorem so John Bell it's a very
interesting story I recommend that you
read Adam Becker's book what is real for
those of you who are mindscape podcast
listeners I interviewed Adam about his
book that he wrote about the history of
quantum mechanics in the twentieth
century and how hard it was for people
post 1935 to get any traction thinking
about the foundations of quantum theory
so John Bell was a particle physicist at
quantum field theories he were concerned
he did very respectable work in particle
physics and sort of in his spare time
and without telling anybody he thought
about the foundations of quantum
mechanics and Bell's Theorem I'm not
going to quote all the details it's sort
of a famously confusing thing to get the
statement of the theory exactly of the
theorem exactly right but basically the
upshot is you can't what's to say what
is the right thing to say no local
theory that is to say no theory in which
strictly speaking influences only ever
travel slower than the speed of light
can we pin match the predictions of
quantum mechanics and he quantified this
in what are called the bell inequalities
okay I should by the way give credit to
David Bohm who was a another
controversial quantum mechanical figure
that you can read about in Adam Becker's
book it was Bohm who first did who first
cast the EPR thought experiment in terms
of spins EPR themselves talked about
something closer to this momentum
example that we gave they talked about
positional momentum uncertainty etc it
was Bohm who said you know it's much
easier if you just use spins instead and
so bell was extremely moved by BOMs
analysis and he proved his theorem and
the reason why it's hard to state the
consequence of the theorem exactly is
just because the when you say match the
predictions of quantum mechanics the
predictions of quantum mechanics are
statistical right there's a certain
probability that certain HAP that
certain things happen and basically what
Bell's Theorem says is that any local
Theory he's going to have the feature
that you can't have the same
probabilities that you have in quantum
mechanics and in fact this is a testable
prediction and people have now done the
tests you know years later it took a
while but people have done the test and
of course quantum mechanics comes off
looking great so roughly speaking Bell
has proven that what Einstein Podolsky
and Rosen were looking for cannot
possibly exist now there are loopholes
of course the most obvious loophole is
let your theory be non-local okay so
that's not really a loophole it's just
saying fine let you know people
misinterpret Bell's Theorem as saying
you can't have hidden variables hidden
variable theories are what EPR were had
in back of their minds but they didn't
talk about them in their paper they
didn't they weren't proposing some new
hidden variable theory Louie Dubrow
invented a hidden variable theory and he
actually spoke about it at the sold a
meeting in 1927 and he got a hard time
especially from Wolfgang Pauli and you
know if you look at the transcripts of
the meeting deploy was completely right
and Polly was completely wrong but
he was just so overbearing that debris
backs down and ignored his own theory
for a long time
Bohm later took up the mantle and
revived Dubois theory so we now call it
the de boi Bohm theory or just bohmian
mechanics sometimes and the point is it
is a hidden variable theory that is
non-local that is explicitly non-local
that admits that influences can exist
that go faster than the speed of light
you can still prove that you can't use
them to communicate but it bites that
bullet it leads into the non locality
and bohmian mechanics was constructed
before Bell made his theorem and in fact
whelming mechanics was one of the
inspiration for Bell's Theorem so it is
very weird that today a lot of
physicists think that Bell proved that
hidden variable theories don't work
because he actually believed in hidden
variable theories and was inspired by
them what he proved is that local hidden
variable theories won't work so that's
an obvious way out of this conundrum but
there are two other ways out different
ways you can choose to fight the bullet
so two other assumptions that go into
proving Bell's Theorem one assumption is
that experiments have gotten outcomes so
when you measure the spin of a particle
I said definite give me a break
I said you get either spin up or spin
down right that sounds like you got a
definite outcome to that experiment
there is a little loophole though right
what if when you do that experiment both
outcomes become real but in different
copies of reality what if there's one
copy of reality where it's spin up and
one copy of reality where it's spin down
what if there are different universes
different worlds one might say in which
you get different measurement outcomes
if that's true then Bell's Theorem just
doesn't apply right Bell assumes that
you get definite measurement outcomes
and in something like the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics you
don't the wavefunction you do as a
person but the wave function of the
universe does not so Bell's Theorem just
doesn't say anything the other one which
is a little bit even weirder I'm not
gonna talk about it too much is that
there is no
super determinism I mean I say it's
weird I think it's weird but there are
other people who love it so I shouldn't
say it's weird it's something that I am
not personally a fan of but we'd be
happy to be wrong if it were proven
wrong so super determinism is roughly
speaking the following idea determinism
like Laplace and Newton had is if I knew
everything that the universe was doing
any one moment in time I can use the
equations of physics to predict the
future or retro dick the past it's
deterministic there's nothing random
nothing stochastic okay super
determinism says that but also says and
there are some initial conditions you're
not allowed to consider okay so in other
words it's not so in the laplacian way
of looking at things
you give me any set of positions and
velocities any possible initial
condition to start with and I can
predict what the universe will do super
determinism adds a restriction on the
set of conditions the set of universes
you're allowed to consider and basically
you could cook the books in a theory
like this where you imagine that certain
kinds of experiments are just never done
right so if the universe did those
experiments then you would violate bells
inequalities or you would actually not
violate them Bell says do quantum
mechanics does violate his inequalities
but the rules of super determinism say
but the universe never chooses to do
those experiments so you would never
know okay and this sounds a little kooky
but I mean there are people who are very
much against it it's like if that's true
if you don't even let me imagine doing
certain experiments that how can I get
by doing science at all but there are
other people including Gerardo tuff who
is one of the greatest living
theoretical physicists who thinks this
is the right way to go so I want to list
it as absolutely a possible loophole to
Bell's Theorem people sometimes ask
about how important Bell's Theorem is so
how important it is depends on what
you're trying to do if your project if
you're if you're in the foundations of
quantum mechanics and your project is
trying to construct the best new theory
of quantum mechanics you know better
than many worlds or bombing mechanics or
anything
then Bell's Theorem is one of the most
important results that you should have
in mind because you better be able to
match the prediction the Bell's Theorem
because it's a very strong prediction
and it's been tested experimentally okay
so if you're trying to emit a new theory
of quantum mechanics Bell's Theorem is
really really crucially important if on
the other hand you work in the
foundations of quantum mechanics and you
think that you know what the correct
theory of quantum mechanics is whether
it's bohmian mechanics or many-worlds or
something else then you can stop
worrying about Bell's Theorem presumably
you've already satisfied it right if
you're working with a theory where
Bell's Theorem is already satisfied like
many worlds or bohmian mechanics you
don't have to keep worrying about it
just like if you have classical
mechanics momentum is conserved no
matter what Hamiltonian you choose you
don't have to keep rechecking that
momentum is conserved as long as the
Hamiltonian is independent of time
momentum is conserved that's a theorem
that you can prove ok all right so
that's Bell's Theorem very very
important if you're trying to invent new
theories of quantum mechanics so what is
the right theory of quantum mechanics so
you know there's different things that
you can do and now what I'm going to do
I sort of we've eaten our vegetables is
is the point I've tried to teach you
what entanglement is and some of its
implications and now we're gonna try to
put it to use so let's do the most
famous thought experiment ever in
quantum mechanics you've all heard of it
Schrodinger's cat and again here's
Schroder coming up with a thought
experiment and then you know I sort of
said EPR were not merely stating their
irritation when they wrote their paper
they were trying to make an argument
based on very clearly stated assumptions
with the cat furniture really was more
or less expressing his irritation
because remember Schrodinger I believe
it is true didn't like the probabilistic
interpretation that Max Born attached to
his wavefunction the schrödinger's wave
function and part of it was the idea of
the quantum world versus the classical
world you know part of the Copenhagen
interpretation is that individual
quantum system
obey the rules of quantum mechanics they
have wave functions the way functions
collapse and you observe them but the
observers are treated using the rules of
classical mechanics and there's even
something called the Heisenberg cut
which divides the microscopic quantum
world from the macroscopic classical
world nobody ever liked this including
the people who invented the Copenhagen
interpretation but they learned to like
it in some sense other people like
Schrodinger and later Everett and so
forth just rebelled entirely at this
idea that you should treat macroscopic
systems as non quantum mechanical of
course a macroscopic system like a
person or a cat can be approximated very
very well by the rules of classical
mechanics we all agree on that the
question is at the deeper level should
we think of cats and people as also
quantum mechanical just like we do the
atoms of which they are made and what
Schrodinger tries to do with his cat
example is to take quantum mechanical
features like the fact that a spin can
be in a superposition of up or down and
amplify that to the macroscopic world so
I don't want to be labor the actual
experiment you've probably seen it
before there is a source a radioactive
source that is you know emitting
radiation with some random frequency
there is a detector a Geiger counter
oops detector Geiger counter that clicks
when the radioactive source releases
something and the detector smashes a
vial with poisonous gas okay and the gas
if the detector clicks the vial is
smashed the gas is released there is a
cat here's the cat in the box okay and
in fur diggers original version of the
thought experiment the gas was cyanide
and it kills the cat if it's released in
my version of the thought experiment
since I want to be kinder to the cat we
make it sleeping gas and if the gas is
released then the cat falls asleep okay
and so here's the cat sleeping like that
and the point is Schrodinger's point in
this thought experiment
sure it might be the case that there is
an experiment in a box like this with
the property that I don't know whether
the gas got released and therefore I
don't know whether the cat is awake or
asleep okay but that's not what quantum
mechanics says quantum mechanics says if
you believe the Copenhagen
interpretation quantum mechanics says
that there is an amplitude right there's
a quantum mechanical wave function for
the cat
after all this happens sigh cat goes
into a superposition something like 1
over square root of 2 cat is awake plus
cat is asleep this is under the
assumption that the cat itself does not
count as an observer okay but Fourier is
sort of poking fun at the Copenhagen
interpretation because the Copenhagen
interpretation never tells us what
counts as an observer so Schrodinger
says if I imagine that only people are
observers then by something like this I
would put the cat which is a big
macroscopic object into a superposition
of awake in the sleep and it is only
when I open the box
and I as a human being observe the cat
that the cat collapses it's wave
function becomes either awake or asleep
and fertig respond tis come on surely
you don't believe that surely you don't
believe that in this box there is a cat
that is neither awake nor asleep but
it's in a superposition of both until I
open the box and then it's both ok so
now you can mess with the details of
this experiment or not but what I want
to do is try to tell a different story
so what we want to do is be a little bit
more careful ok about the system that
we're dealing with here because the
point of entanglement remember and this
is why entanglement is crucial to this
story the point of entanglement is that
we should never really talk about the
wave function of individual parts of the
quantum mechanical system we should only
ever talk about the wave function of the
system as a whole
ok the system all at once because the
different parts of the system can be
entangled now there might be certain
special circumstances under
part of the system sort of separated out
and is not entangle with the rest of the
world that's completely allowed but
often systems will be entangled and in
particular in a situation like this they
very much will be so let's ask the
question what if we include in the wave
function not just the wave function of
the cat but the wave function of an
observer as well okay so what happens
when the observer opens the box and
Schrodinger no could have made the MM if
he did make this argument or not but it
he certainly has something like this in
mind himself he says you know what we
want what we know is true is that
sometimes you see the cat awake
sometimes you see the cat asleep but you
never see the cat in the superposition
of both what that means is if the cat's
wavefunction is a hundred percent awake
then it better be the case that I
observe the cat to be awake and likewise
when the cat is asleep and just from
that fact that if the cat's awake I
observe it awake if the cats asleep I
observe it asleep from that fact and
from the Schrodinger equation I can show
using math using actually very trivial
math that the following thing must be
true so this is sorry for the cat but we
don't want that right this is not the
good way of thinking about quantum
mechanics because the cat is not alone
in the universe so let's write down the
wave function of once you've opened the
box cat plus oops cat plus you you are
the observer and what Schrodinger argues
is that is 1 over square root of 2 cat
awake plus you saw the cat awake
actually I shouldn't say plus here for
technical reasons I should say and
you see it awake that is one part of the
wave function plus the other part of the
wave function is the cat's asleep and
you saw it asleep in other words and
again this is derived from the
Schrodinger equation this is not posited
the state of you is entangled with the
state of the cat okay this is a
prediction of the Schrodinger equation
this is not something we magically
invented this is something it has to be
true if you're any good at all at
noticing whether cats are awake or
asleep if that's the case then given the
setup of the Schrodinger's cat box
experiment this is the state that you
and the cat will evolve into where
there's an entanglement between the cat
being awake and asleep and you observing
the cat awake or asleep okay so you
might ask well why don't we just accept
that who says this isn't what actually
happens and the obvious answer is it
looks like from this expression that you
are in a superposition of having seen
the cat awake and having seen the cat
asleep right but no person has ever
experienced being in a superposition
like that right no person ever ever
opens the box and says oh yes half of me
thinks the cat's awake and 1/2 me sees
things the cat's asleep so it seems
naively sorry that this expression and
even though it's derived from the
Schrodinger equation is completely
empirically inadequate that it is
contradicted by experiment by the
experiments we actually do when we
measure systems even though we don't do
it with cats we could measure systems
like electrons and it's the same exact
thing it's just a fancy way of saying an
electron spin up versus spin down right
okay what's going on
so most people the copenhagen Terp
rotational
I would have to erase one part of the
wave function by hand that is the
collapse of the wave function the other
part would go on as the world half of it
would disappear and it was in fact Hugh
Everett in the 1950s he was a graduate
student working with John Wheeler who
said just keep this rotamer equation
Hugh Everett is the one who invented the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics basically he didn't need to
add any physics this is the crucial
thing you need to understand about many
worlds it doesn't start with quantum
mechanics and say what if there's a lot
of worlds okay Everett says that there's
two crucial steps one is believe in
entanglement which you should do because
it's part of Schrodinger's equation and
the other is just let the Schrodinger
equation do what it says it's doing
don't modify it just believe it it's
okay okay ever it says this expression
is actually what we evolve into right
that's actually true but the crucial
point is we can treat these two
different parts of the wavefunction as
representing two separate worlds and I
think I'll explain why we can do that
but the point is the worlds were always
there wave functions like this we're
always in the set of all possible wave
functions if you believe that an
electron could in principle be in a
superposition of spin up and spin down
then you should be able to believe that
a cat could be in a superposition of
awake and asleep and an observer could
be in a superposition and entangled with
the cat of having seen the cat awake or
sleeping you should believe the whole
universe can be in a superposition of
many different things lots of people
don't want to believe that the
Copenhagen people didn't want to believe
that so they just erased part of the
wave function by hand in flagrant
contradiction to what the Schrodinger
equation predicts whatever it is saying
is more therapeutic than scientific he's
saying don't worry about it it's okay
this is a perfectly good way of thinking
about quantum mechanics now the trick is
what right does he have to say that
these are back two separate worlds and
the answer there is something called
decoherence and here I'm being a little
bit non-historical because Everett
himself didn't know about decoherence
least not in the modern formulation it
really wasn't didn't come on the scene
until the 1970s hans did say and then
later on other people elaborated this
theory but decoherence is the upshot of
taking seriously two things
it's number one there is only one wave
function the wave function of the whole
universe and number two the rest of the
universe is continually bumping into us
the rest of the universe is always
interacting with us and if you believe
there is only one wave function for the
whole universe that means the rest of
the universe if you are a big
macroscopic object you will become
entangled with the rest of the universe
like it or not and that entanglement is
what we call decoherence so we can see
that at work in this example of
Schrodinger's cat let's cut and paste it
move it down here
here we are Avengers cat I'm gonna lose
I'm gonna blow it up a little bit so we
get a can I do that no I cannot do that
all right it's fine it's big enough the
point is that there's a whole bunch of
going on in the box
okay this box is not just vacuum inside
other than the cat and the apparatus
there are particles of air right there's
oxygen and nitrogen and co2 there are
even more photons bouncing around inside
the box there could be some light in the
box if only because the cat is giving
off infrared light etc okay and
therefore this stuff which we call the
environment oops the environment is what
we call everything else in the box all
of the degrees of freedom which is the
fancy way of saying stuff that defines
the quantum state stuff that can move
around have different values all the
degrees of freedom that we don't keep
track of when we tell stories about cats
and detectors and so forth we don't give
you the position or the quantum state of
every other particle in the universe we
just say that's all in the environment
and we generally ignore it but the point
of decoherence is that you can't ignore
it when it comes to quantum mechanics
and the reason why is so let's imagine a
single photon let's just keep track of a
single photon and yeah let's let's make
this photon be yellow so imagine what a
single photon would do moving in the box
and if the cat is awake
there can be a situation where the
photon hits the cat and gets absorbed
by the cat okay because the cat is awake
it's moving around the box the photon
hits it but if the cat were asleep the
cat would be in a different physical
location it's lying on the floor asleep
so if that were the case if they can't
were asleep I can't really draw it very
well but the point is the photon would
continue on okay it would not be
absorbed by the cat so what that means
is the quantum state of the environment
instantly or very almost instantly very
very quickly becomes entangled with that
of the cat the quantum state of the
environment which is what every single
photon in the box is doing monitors
whether the cat is awake or asleep so if
we keep track of that in our wave
function not keep track of the explicit
state of every single photon but simply
keep track of the fact that the
environment has become entangled with
the cat that the state of this
individual photon for example was or was
not absorbed depending on whether the
cat was awake or asleep the real way we
should be writing the wave function is 1
over square root of 2 and let's imagine
that we've opened the box now and looked
at it ok so we have the cat we have our
cells we have you the person who looked
at the cat and we have the environment
so it's 1 over square root of 2 cat
awake you saw the cat away and then
there's an environment associated with
the cat being awake I don't have any
clever way of expressing that but the
point is if the cat is up and awake the
photons and the air molecules are gonna
interact with it in a certain way and
and be affected by it in a certain way
whereas we're gonna and we'll label that
the environment corresponding to the cat
being awake whereas if the cat's asleep
and you saw it asleep then there's a
different environment and we're not
gonna go to the details of what it is
but it's the environment associated with
the cat being asleep and here's the
payoff ok
because these two different environment
states they're actually very different
in fact they are completely separate
they're completely perpendicular to each
other in the space of all possible wave
functions this big vector space that we
call Hilbert space Hilbert space I
forget whether I would I mention this
but this is an important the terminology
Hilbert space named after mathematician
David Hilbert is the space of all
possible wave functions just like phase
space is the space of all possible
positions in momentum Hilbert space is
the space of all possible quantum states
or wave functions and it's a vector
space as a set of vectors is a very very
very big vector space for a single qubit
with just two basis States is a two
dimensional vector space not very big
but for a single particle moving in
space Hilbert space is already infinite
dimensional so a lot of the mathematical
complication in quantum mechanics comes
with dealing with infinite dimensional
vector spaces anyway the point is if a
photon in one part of the quantum state
went on its way and in another part got
absorbed those two states are completely
orthogonal to each other completely
perpendicular to each other as vectors
in Hilbert space and what that means is
that in the rest of the quantum wave
function this versus this go their own
way what happens in the first part of
the wavefunction people moving around
doing experiments interacting with the
rest of the world etc will never in any
way interact with the people in the
other part of the wave function so you
know we call this this whole thing oops
I should get my colors consistent so
call this this
it's getting late in the day here folks
sorry this is a the asleep branch of the
wave function this is the nomenclature
that ever it used and this is the it
again this is the awake branch and
because the environment states are
orthogonal and separate in these two
different parts of the wave function
they evolved completely independently
they do not affect each other
there's no experiment that one person
described by one branch of the wave
function can possibly do to either
affect or be affected by a person in a
different branch of the wave function it
is as if they have become separate
worlds and this is Everett's realization
that the two different branches of the
wave function one in which you see an
awake cat one would you seen a sleep cat
can be treated as completely independent
worlds so he didn't put them in again I
can't emphasize this enough the branches
were always there the wave functions in
hilbert space always had the possibility
of having all of these different
branches in them the Schrodinger
equation predicts that they come true
that's unambiguously everyone agrees
with that if all you have is the short
of your equation you start with a
quantum mechanical experiment the
different branches representing
macroscopic superpositions of different
quantum states will come to pass by the
evolution of the Schrodinger equation
all ever it does is point out and that's
ok as long as you think of yourself as
living only on one branch and not the
other all the other branches Ted Bundy
was a physicist friend of mine pointed
out that every other interpretation of
quantum mechanics should be called a
disappearing world's interpretation of
quantum mechanics because the
many-worlds is just let's keep the
Schrodinger equation so let me emphasize
this by writing it down what ever
invented was the many-worlds
interpretation he didn't call it that
but he didn't mind it being called that
and it has precisely two postulates okay
zero the postulates say there are many
worlds that's a prediction that is
implication of the postulates pause
so that one is the quantum states are
vectors or functions if you like doesn't
really matter in Hilbert space it's just
a fancy way of saying quantum states are
wave functions that's all we're saying
and the Schrodinger equation is correct
all the time in the Copenhagen
interpretation the Schrodinger equation
is not always correct in the clip in the
Copenhagen interpretation the
Schrodinger equation is correct
until you observe something and then the
wavefunction collapses and that collapse
of the wave function is not governed by
the short of your equation so these are
the two postulates from which you derive
that there exist branches they act as
separate worlds etc so that's the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics and the reason why it's nice
is because the remember we talked about
two problems in the last video the
measurement problem what do you mean by
making measurement and the reality
problem what is actually real so many
worlds offers an extraordinarily simple
answer to both questions what is a
measurement a measurement is when a
quantum system that is in a
superposition becomes entangled with the
wider world with the environment in
particular and therefore the universe
branches into multiple copies that go
their own way that's what a measurement
is there's nothing to do with
consciousness nothing to do with people
nothing to do with what anything that
happens in your brain the other problem
was the reality problem what is reality
is the wave function just a way of
making predictions but it's not really
reality is the wave function part of
reality but there's also hidden
variables or something else ever it
gives the simplest possible answer the
wave function is reality and it is all a
reality there's nothing that it's
missing and there's nothing that it
forgets to describe okay you don't need
anything extra to describe the world so
this is the purest simplest most austere
version of quantum mechanics and it is
an actual physical theory unlike the
Copenhagen interpretation which is just
a set of rules that asks you not to ask
certain questions this is a fully formed
rigorously defined physical theory
any question you want to ask can in
principle be answered within many worlds
that's why many of us find it very very
compelling not everyone finds it
compelling so there are problems with
many worlds one problem is reproducing
the probability rule the born rule will
be say in quantum mechanics is the
probability of seeing a measurement
outcome is given by the wave function
squared but in Everett the probability
of any particular measurement outcome
coming to pass is a hundred percent in
one of the branches so how do you assign
probabilities to different branches I'm
not going to go into any of these
questions here I've given plenty of
talks online you can look a bit on my
talks about quantum mechanics I wrote a
book something deeply hidden where I
talk about these a lot all I want to do
is emphasize that this is a well-defined
physical theory it is not an
interpretation in the conventional sense
and there might have been a time in the
bad old days when people said well we
don't really know what quantum mechanics
is about we have to interpret it in a
certain way this is not an
interpretation this is a physical theory
and there are competing physical
theories and this is just science it is
not literary criticism or something like
that this is all falsifiable
experimentally testable science so
there's various alternatives to many
worlds so we know we can sort of think
about what the alternatives can be given
what we've already said right one our
hidden variable theories bohmian
mechanics for example and bamhi
mechanics is basically you have the
wavefunction but you also have particles
with locations okay
the wavefunction guides the particles
around but in some sense it's the
particles that are really representing
reality in the wavefunction disorder
gets in the way it's a little weird to
people like me balmy mechanics because
for a number of reasons one is the
fundamental equations have the following
weird feature that the wave function
still obeys the Schrodinger equation so
even though there's these extra things
the particles and the particles are
guided by the wave function
what the particles are doing does not
affect the wavefunction so it seems to
violate again at least the spirit if not
the letter of Newton's third law right
for every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction you expect if the
wavefunction pushes the particles the
particles would push back on the
wavefunction that is not true in bohmian
mechanics and of course the way that the
wavefunction influences the particles is
non-local because it has to be non-local
because of Bell's Theorem for me though
the real reason why bohmian mechanics is
not that compelling is because exactly
because you need these extra hidden
variables it becomes very problematic
well we don't know what the right
variables are if you're doing a bunch of
nonrelativistic particles if you're
doing you know the hydrogen atom or
whatever then bomi mechanics works
perfectly well but if you're doing
quantum field theory or if you're doing
quantum gravity and you're not even sure
what the right variables are in a hidden
variable Theory every time you think
about a new set of physical stuff you
need to reinvent the rules from scratch
what are the variables how are they
guided etc whereas many-worlds is
plug-and-play you tell me what the
variables are you tell me what their
Hamiltonian is I have the Schrodinger
equation I'm done ok so for those of us
who are interested in pushing the laws
of physics beyond what we currently know
into more speculative realms about
quantum gravity and unification and so
forth hidden variables are not nearly as
compelling as many worlds as many worlds
as much simpler another very popular
approach is objective collapse models so
here you bite the bullet in terms of the
collapse of the wavefunction you know
the Copenhagen interpretation says when
you make a measurement wavefunction
suddenly collapse it doesn't give you
details about what that means ok the
objective collapse models like hidden
variables or like many worlds are well
posed rigorous physical theories that
tell you exactly when wave functions
collapse but they believe the wave
functions collapse so there are either
spontaneous collapses there's a theory
called the grw theory Gerardi Remini in
beber and basically what they say is
every electron every particle in nature
as a chance of having a sweet function
to spontaneously collapse it's very rare
for every electron it might be like once
every 300 million years but in something
like a table there's way more than 300
million electrons so things that are
macroscopic in size have their
individual constituents constantly
collapsing their wave functions and that
keeps us in more or less well-defined
classical trajectories so the good news
is that that you know is compatible with
what we've observed so far about the
behavior of quantum systems the better
news is that it might not be compatible
with what we observe if we improve our
observations so the idea that a
wavefunction spontaneously collapses so
you go from a wave function looks like
this just randomly in obvious violation
of the Schrodinger equation
it goes turns into something like that
with some probability well you know the
energy of the wave function changes
suddenly right this blatantly violates
energy conservation - violates
determinism it's a truly stochastic
theory so if you have some collection of
atoms that is really really cold low
temperature making it something called a
bose-einstein condensate and you wait
around if you have millions of atoms
occasionally one of those atoms will
heat up by the collapse of the
wavefunction the grw theory and so this
is an experimental test that can
actually be done and if it's done and if
they find it if they find the wave
functions objectively collapse you will
have what we call falsified the
many-worlds interpretation because
people ask you know how can you falsify
version of quantum mechanics which has
all these worlds you can't interact with
but that's not the postulate of many
worlds the postulates of many worlds are
there wavefunction to describe reality
and they obey the Schrodinger equation
if you do an experiment that explicitly
shows a system violating the Schrodinger
equation you have falsified many worlds
the easiest theory to falsify in the
world in principle I don't think it will
be falsified because I don't think it's
false but there you go you can also have
induced collapse which says that rather
than just randomly collapsing when a
system reaches a certain threshold of
some criterion then the wavefunction
collapses so Roger Penrose
theory when the gravitational field of
two branches of the wavefunction differs
by a certain amount and one of them
disappears and the other one becomes
reality and I'm not moved by these
particular versions of quantum mechanics
because they seem incredibly @ha if they
are I think it's impossible to deny they
are incredibly ad-hoc you've made up
this rule but the people who like the
rules would say well yeah we made it up
to fit the data I would say yeah but I
didn't need to make up that rule to fit
the data cuz I have a theory that fits
the data without that rule and they
would say I don't like your theory for
this or that reason and maybe they're
right
so that's why it's crucially important
in physics in general and quantum
mechanics in particular to have let a
thousand flowers bloom let many
different people go and study many
different theories to see what the
predictions are and test them against
each other so I could be wrong but these
alternatives exist and again these
alternatives are not interpretations
these are different physical theories
that we are testing this is not literary
criticism it's just doing science and
finally you know there's many other if
you go to Wikipedia is like 16 different
interpretations of quantum mechanics
which really should be called
formulations of quantum mechanics but
they don't okay but there's many of them
I'm not gonna list all of them the other
approach so if you if you sort of
imagine a flowchart here you have in
conventional quantum mechanics wave
functions in the Schrodinger equation so
one line of the flowchart is do you do
you believe that entirely and if yes you
go to many worlds one line says you want
to violate the Schrodinger equation and
in that case you go to objective
collapse one line says do you need more
than the wavefunction to describe
reality and in that case you go to
hidden variables and finally there's a
line that says do you not even need the
wavefunction to describe reality does
the wavefunction not represent reality
at all is the wavefunction is the tool
you use to predict probabilities and
that approach does under the name the
epistemic versions of quantum mechanics
epistemic meaning knowledge of
epistemology is our study of knowledge
and how we know things so an epistemic
approach to quantum mechanics says wave
functions are not
reality wave functions are what we know
about the predictions that we're going
to make now my problem with epistemic
approaches one is called the most famous
one is called quantum Bayesian ISM
actually it used to be called quantum
Bayesian ISM the advocates have now
shortened that to just cubism because
it's cuter and every version of quantum
mechanics uses Bayesian ISM in some way
or another so cubism is what it's called
or quantum Bayesian ISM and you know
that I have two objections to this one
is I certainly don't want to give up on
the prospect of describing reality right
it is not sufficient in my mind to say I
have an algorithm that makes predictions
for experimental outcomes I actually
want to know what's going on in reality
secondly you know there are people who
work on epistemic approaches who agree
with me that you should be able to
describe reality but they just say well
we don't know what that is yet so all
we're working with is the ability to
make predictions but people have tried
and they failed there are reasons to
believe that the simplest most
straightforward ways of making a realist
theory some ontology as we would call it
in philosophy some version of what is
actually happening in the world and
mapping it on to the formalism of the
epistemic approaches to quantum
mechanics is not going to work it's not
a completely airtight theory because the
thing about mathematical theorems is
they rely on assumptions and if you
violate the assumptions you can wriggle
out of the implications of the theorems
but it is a well-posed scientific
approach even though again I'm not a fan
of hidden variables objective collapse
or epistemic approaches they're all on
the table as interesting things so the
point is the point is not to say that I
know what the correct theory is and it's
many-worlds the point is that in the
modern version of quantum mechanics what
we call foundations of quantum mechanics
is what we used to call interpretations
of quantum mechanics we are actually
comparing truly different well
formulated scientific theories we're not
fuzzy minded anymore and one of these
theories may be right or none of them
may be right we may be yet to find the
right theory but the quest to find the
right theory is perfectly scientific and
I would argue that it is of absolutely
utmost importance to the progress of
science both philosophically in that
this is what science should be doing if
quantum mechanics is the most accurate
most reliable version of reality that we
have we should do our best to understand
it but also practically you know I do
think and this is a longer story and
again you can read my book or look
online at the talks we are stuck in some
way in fundamental physics in trying to
go beyond the standard model of particle
physics understand dark energy the big
bang things like that the nature of
black holes part of me says well should
you really be surprised that we're stuck
if we don't even understand quantum
mechanics right if we don't even agree
on what the foundations of our best
physical Theory actually say now main
most of my physics friends would
disagree with me about that they would
say sure maybe you want to understand
quantum mechanics but that's separate
from trying to understand quantum
gravity or unification or dark energy or
anything like that I have a suspicion
that they are not separate I have
suspicions that they are related to each
other which is why I'm trying to move
forward in going from understanding
quantum mechanics to making predictions
about space-time and field theory and
stuff like that but it's hard and it
might fail you know it's I'm not gonna
try to hype it as the answer to all the
questions it is the way forward that I
find personally most attractive but it
could easily fail that's how science
works that's okay that is not a bug of
science that is a feature we try our
best we make hypotheses we follow them
we see where we go in the case of
understanding quantum mechanics it's one
of the most interesting and exciting
things to think about and I'm very
interested to see where we go